欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这一节课我们来讲一下
循环转化率低
我们要去怎么样去提升
首先我们要先找到它
转化率低的
具体的原因
然后再针对
这些原因
采用不同的方法去提升就可以了
第一个就是
先从大范围去找
也就是店铺流量成绩
第二个就是从
产品流量成绩去找
第三个就是从
自动车流量成绩去找
这个是小范围的
那么这个整个店铺的流量
都是由这两个小的流量
累积而达成的
这个店铺成绩的流量
那么我们来看一下
店铺流量成绩
影响循环转化的指标
具体有哪些
第一个就是
关键词
你要去看
关键词是否精准
从引流关键词
这个板块去看
这些关键词的
精准性
第二个就是我们要去看
我们的访客国家是否准确
也就是我们店铺来的访客
的这些人群
他们对应的国家
是不是我们目标市场的国家
这个从买家参谋里面去看
这样的话
那才能够判断出
寻盘转化低的原因
如果这两个都不精准
那么寻盘转化率一定是很低的
那么我们就针对这些去优化就可以了
针对这些优化
要怎么优化呢
肯定是从产品
还有直通车
这两个板块
更细的维度去解决这个问题
第二个就是价格跟起定量
你的价格是否合理
是否符合当下市场的需求
起定量是否能够让更多买家能够接受这个起定量
你可以去参考榜单中行业优秀的那些产品
以及你可以去买家参谋里面的行业数据里面去看
这些价格跟起定量
它的大致范围是在哪里
也可以在商品洞察里面去看
这些整个平台的价格跟起定量都是在哪些范围
你的会不会太高或者是太低
如果你太高的话太高
那么你是很难获得寻盘的
所以寻盘总化率就会太低
那么第二个就是如果你价格太低的话
寻盘可能有了
但是你最终能够成交的概率很小
因为你的真实的价格可能无法接受
你只是通过低价遗留
但是来的客户并不能长交
第三个就是店铺流量少
从流量提升切入
也就是你的寻盘转化率低
会不会是因为你的店铺的总的流量很少
总的流量少也就是访客太少了
点击太少了
那么这种就是基础数据量太少
我们就应该从流量层击先去提升
从流量层击提升呢
肯定就是从产品
还有就是自动的推广这两个板块
入手是最快的
所以这这是一个解决的思路
第四个就是你的店铺里面非常非常多的高点机
高访客的产品
但是它的寻盘转化很低
你可以在产品分析三日天里面去看数据
看看你的产品哪些是高点机高访客
但是寻盘很少
甚至没有寻盘的这些产品
你要针对这些产品进行详细的分析
那么产品详细的分析
就到了我们这第二个维度
产品流量层击了
那么它是这样的
先从大的范围去判断
流量哪些板块存在问题
然后再到小的这个板块
小的板块明确了之后
你就再针对这个板块
产品板块里面的一些更加细致的指标
去进行分析就可以了
第二个层级就是产品流量层级
就是针对单品或者是多个产品进行一个分析
第一个就是自然流量跟直通车流量分析
也就是你店铺里面自然流量有没有增长
直通车流量有没有提升
这两个板块是非常重要的
因为这个板块你的直通车只要预算设定了没有增长
那么你只有自然流量在持续的增长
你的整个店铺流量总的流量才会增长
所以这个逻辑一定要理解清楚
同时你要去关注这些流量的占比
第二个就是我们刚才从这边所讲的这些高点机
高访客
然后转化低的产品这些方法去优化
就可以了
第三个就是如果你的整个店铺的爆品和优品的重量少
那么你一定要想办法去提升这些数量
因为你的这些数量少
那么你整体的流量肯定是会少的
因为你的很多池是没有排名的
所以说这个总量一定要去提升
具体怎么样去提升
我们可以参考我们前面所学的方法
第四个就是优质产品排名决定着流量的大小
也就是你店铺里面有没有那种真爆品
非常爆效果非常好的那种产品
这种产品它通常会有很多关键词
那么这些关键词的排名的稳定性
以及这些关键词本身流量的大小
就决定着我们整个店铺产品的流量大小
所以这个板块一定要着重的去看和去研究
特别是你头部可能有三到五个非常好的产品
那么这个时候你一定要去确保它的整体的流量的稳定性
第三个就是自动车流量的层级
自动车流量层级我们是直接可以参考我们自动车板块
自动车诊断自动车优化这些方法直接去操作就可以了
通常来说我们只要记住一个原则就是从
高点机的国家这些维度去分析就可以了
主要是从高点机高消耗这些维度去分析
那么另一个就是判断它的各种指标的一个精准性如何
如果精准性不行我们就针对性的去优化自动车就可以了
那么这个就是我们关于循环转化率低
怎么样去分析以及怎么样去提升的一些思路跟方法
我们这里主要讲的是思路
方法的话我们前面也已经讲了具体的方法了
那么我们来打开后台来给大家演示一下怎么样去分析
首先我们如果第一次全电分析的时候
我们一定是从整体的数据概览去进行分析的
那么数据概览这里我们肯定是按照周或者是按照月的维度去看的
那么这里我可以按照月的维度去看
这里你看我看先看月你看这些数据指标和之前的数据指标进行对比
如果你已经把这里的数据已经统计在表格了
那么你只需要去看你那个综合的数据表就能够去分析了
首先看询盘转化低
询盘转化低我们首先要去看访客
如果这里的访客人数基础量不多的时候
那么你询盘本来就很少
如果这里的访客很多
那么我们就来看一下
你看你访客的国家分布
是不是你想要的目标国家
如果这里都不是我们的目标国家
那么这里的巡盘肯定很少
第二个我们来看一下买家参谋这里
我们来看一下自己店铺里面的访问买家
那么我们来看一下这些国家的分布
是不是我们目标市场的
如果这些都不是
那么就说明我们的引流发生了偏差
我们需要在产品的款式属性等等去发布的时候
就要去选择我们目标国家更加偏好的这种类型
重新选品才能够解决这个问题
第二个就是我们在直动家推广的时候
很狠的锁定这些目标国家才能够真正的扭转
这就是我们所说的访客
第二个就是我们刚才说的关键词是不是不精准
我们来看一下这个引流关键词
我们来看也是看10月份的
那么这里我们都是选择全部
全部之后我们看一下我们店铺里面的引流关键词
是不是我们想要的词
是不是我们精准的词
你看这些是不是你想要的词
是不是精准
这些点击是带来流量的
这些都是带来流量的
如果都是准确的
那么说明你的词还是精准确的
那么这个时候
如果你的国家也准确
词也准确
那么这个时候你就要去考虑
比如刚才我们讲的可能是价格的问题
产品价格问题和起定量的问题
产品价格起定量的问题
那么你就去榜单这里看
比如说我找到一个榜单
比如说这一榜单
你去看每个品类
这些同行你可以点开10到20个去看
他们的价格区间都在哪里
他们价格区间
跟你的价格区间
是不是有差距的
那么我们来看一下
产品发现
这里有一个自定义产品
我们来这里面去看一下
它的一个价格区间是怎么样的
按照品类
你选的品类
你看这里有个品类
你选选这些品类
去看一下它的价格区间
是不是符合整个平台的
你看
粉色的是询盘
发询盘比较多的一个价格区间
商品数
蓝色的是商品数比较多的这些数量
那么这个你要去看这些就可以了
这个就是我们说的价格跟起定量
这些你要去这些维度去分析
那么接着我们是不是就要去看产品了
看产品我们也是要按照月去看
看哪些高访问的
你看这些访问
是不是有寻盘呢
比如说你看这种访问那么多
为什么没有寻盘
那么针对这种情况我们就细致到这个产品层级了
那么产品层级你就按照这几个维度去分析
比如说这个产品你要就要从里面去分析
词是否精准
访客是否精准
价格起定量等等都要综合分析
最后面再到详情页里面去分析
看看是不是你的详情页的问题
所以说我们分析的时候
先从大维度逐渐的盘点
然后缩陷到小的维度
最后面确定具体的影响指标
就能够去找到我们具体的问题去解决了
这样的话才能够真正的从本质上去解决这个店铺流量的问题
那么这个产品的层级
还有另外两个就是全店的优品数
优品数的话
我们可以在产品商品管理这里
就是有个优品工作台
优品运营
那么这里面你去看你的包品总量有没有增加
或者是整体的一个优品总量多不多
这样也可以去分析
接着就是你非常火爆产品的排名
这个决定着你的整个单品的流量的稳定性
比如说我们在产品分析这里
我们要按UX去看
找到你店铺最火爆的那几个产品
去看一下他的这些关键词的排名啊
以及他流量的稳定性
流量的稳定性的话我们就是从
他的关键词进来看
他拉长之后就知道他的流量稳定性
或者是说看他的指数进12个月
搜索指数的一个稳定性
这样的稳
越多
而且他排名越好
那么他整个产品的流量的稳定性就会越高
接着就是直动车的分析
直动车的分析的话
我们这里就不展开讲了
因为我们有直动车的具体的课程
那个课程里面会讲的非常非常详细的
你就按照那个思路去打开你直动车的后台
然后去进行按照标准化的方法去分析就可以了
按照这个流程从左到右去分析就可以了
那么这样你就能够一步一步的找到所有的问题
然后应用具体的方法去解决就可以了
那么这些就是从大范围到小范围的分析
你的思路大范围里面要分析哪些指标
小范围里面又要分析哪些指标
更小的维度你又要分析哪些指标
从这样的思路去盘点去分析
然后找到具体的某一个核心的问题
针对这个问题再去解决
那么你这个寻盘总化率低的问题
才能够从本质上得到解决
这节课我们就先讲到这里
希望大家能够根据这种思路去演练一遍
你只有做多几次你才能够记忆深刻
才能够把它掌握